I'm looking for a story,...
...a place to spark it.
I was always encouraged to look beyond,...
...to cross frontiers.
Life is not just a ride you jump on.
You make it your own.
You open trails.
I work hard on not letting things become familiar.
I love strange territories, the heartbeat of uncertainty,...
...the constant change of the landscape.
I seek the soul of people,...
...not what they do, but who they are.
Traveling helps me to keep perspective,...
...remember what's important:...
...the beauty of a flower, of a smile.
I was taught not to take things for granted,...
...to treasure every breath I take, to taste every flavor.
Each moment triggers my next step,...
...passion, inspiration, new places, new sensations...
...are all relentless, addictive things I pump into my blood.
Each mile walked, each new friend...
...are the things I treasure the most.
I can have nothing but that, yet that is so much.
I pay tribute to life by enjoying the most simple things:...
...unfamiliar habitats, strange encounters, facing fears...
...and fearing nothing.
I find myself living on a roller coaster...
...and still have the time to stop and contemplate.
I seek a unique experience to tell my story...
...and I know where to start.